45 years after David Bowie first sang
about life on Mars a new exhibition at
the Design Museum is exploring the
challenges humans might face if we lived
on the Red Planet
there's the lethal space radiation we'd
have to cope with harsh temperatures and
dust storms
not to mention sourcing our own water
and growing our own food pulling the
mission off isn't only gonna require a
giant leap forward in space travel it's
gonna have to be humanity's greatest
feat in design living in an inflatable
pod under a cave might take a little bit
of getting used to as for the inside
well an estate agent might say it's cozy
this little workshop here that we have
so much you want to do some work here
you can do that this design was produced
by a team of architects as part of a
challenge set by NASA on earth we have
magnetic poles which means all the
radiation has deflected off all Mars is
gonna hit us it's gonna be very
dangerous so the best thing to do is
they've always in a cave so this cave is
really or the shell structures would be
3d printed by the robots that you see
moving your mouse along there designs
like these are a persuasive argument
that we could eventually find a way to
live on Mars but not everyone's
convinced we should we have this
wonderful piece in the exhibition which
is a new commission by Alexandra Daisy
Ginsburg who's a young designer and she
said very openly I think you know this
is a supreme arrogance on the part of
humans to think of Mars as belonging to
us and as the sort of Plan B in case
something terrible happens here on earth
and her proposal is to not treat Mars as
a lifeboat boat for humans but as a
lifeboat for non-human forms of life
like bacteria and plants about a hundred
times further away than the moon but
arguably one of the biggest obstacles we
face comes down to something rather more
basic going to Mars is a very expensive
proposition and it means that the
governments around the world will come
will have to come together and say it's
something we want to do together and you
know at the moment we don't show many
signs of working together very well
internationally finding the money will
be crucial for the
Oh peas in pushing ahead with design
ideas it should make it a little easier
to persuade people
it's a journey worth making Katie
Spencer Sky News